allez direction Cheverny à présent vous
connaissez le château mais en ce moment
les stars ce sont ces tulipes il faut
dire qu'elles sont nombreuses un demi
million au total et de toutes les
couleurs avec le pouvoir de mettre de
bonne humeur et d'attirer les visites
vous voyez ce reportage de Laura Chauvet
rose
rouge chaque printemps des milliers de
tulipes colorées en veille le parc du
château de Cheverny pour le plus grand
plaisir des visiteurs je n'ai jamais vu
autant de tulipes comme ça je trouve que
c'est très beau moi je trouve que c'est
magnifique c'est un vrai plaisir des
yeux et en aucun cas je n'aurais loupé
ça encore cette année cette année
justement le domaine voit les choses en
grand en un mois 500 mille bulles ont
été plantés à la main soit deux fois
plus que l'année dernière un véritable
challenge quand ça arrive avec des
semi-remorques on se dit on a un petit
moment d'hésitation est-ce qu'on va y
arriver avec de la réflexion avec des
soutiens des uns et des autres on a
réussi à le faire on a sûrementé ce
challenge parce que déjà que 250 000
c'est de saleté c'était vraiment un vrai
challenge le visiteur est satisfait donc
on est amplement satisfait aussi de
l'autre côté 10 ans après la création de
cet événement le pari est aujourd'hui
réussi le nombre de visiteurs est passé
de 1300 à 2000 par jour c'était une
manière très
religieuse de nous distinguer sur
l'échiquier des châteaux de la Loire et
puis surtout ça permettait d'apporter à
Cheverny une autre notoriété et cette
fois dans le domaine des jardins pour
réaliser ces bandeaux de tulipes au
minimum 40 000 euros ont été investis
[Musique]